they're going into this Spidey
production I feel like I should be
confident but I'm not doing drugs is
that what this is is this gross I just
got back from Hawaii pretty fun little
vacation with my family and I brought
these guys back some goodies to share
with the crew
they've all been working really hard and
they need some treats so there's some
macadamia nut chocolate things down
there I also was able to bring back
something more interesting and unique I
think I basically met some locals they
grow cacao beans and they actually sold
me some some Raquel beans here cacao is
what chocolate is made from you can
refine it down to cocoa which is what
happened to our chocolate bars and
everything they are a mild stimulant so
they have some caffeine like properties
drugs is that what what this is
I mean smells like chocolate yeah it
tastes like kind of like really like
coffee grounds or really plain dark
chocolate these were actually first
cultivated in South America the Mayans
used to call this the food of the gods
they believed that the gods gave them
this gift of these beans why did they
think that because they actually have
healing properties when they're prepared
correctly and Mayans had this drink that
they prepare was the first like instance
of hot chocolate ever their culture
valued it so highly that they use it in
all these ceremonies even as emergency
here the thing about currency currency
isn't the value unless you're on it
being standard it's the representation
of value so I guess we're gonna
determine today how much value these
beans have I'm gonna actually attempt to
make this ancient Mayan elixir here in
the studio and we're gonna try it
people feel effects I don't know exactly
what spiritual awakening means when I
kind of without a spiritual awakening
what are you talking to just go with it
we got some herbs and spices mixed with
these magic beans I've never done this
before so we're gonna learn together
we're gonna we're gonna learn as we go
here so this is supposed to make you
calm it's supposed to make through
energized actually guys yeah we're and
if you have too much it'll make you you
for it we're not gonna drink a high dose
there because this is all of our first
time doing this ceremony is it chocolate
yes like ritualistic Mayan yeah yeah
actually so we're gonna have to like tie
someone down to a table and cut up on
their stress you just knot it are you
gonna make hot chocolate is that what
you're doing I'm going to make ancient
Mayan hot chocolate yes I'm really
curious about how this makes you feel
Danny is this the biggest video you've
ever made
yeah I think this is the biggest video
I've ever met it Danny and Nico our two
boys they're going to do this
Spidey production it's gonna be the
first video that they've shot together
Danny now has been working here for a
few months but the difference between
Danny's content and the stuff that we
make is we have structured scenes we
have action scenes we have conventional
storytelling so it's really going to be
important for Nico to come in and help
guide that process for Danny I feel like
I should be confident but I'm not I feel
like we've accounted for everything but
because I'm so new to this and this is
like my biggest thing that I've done I'm
not confident that I have thought of
everything I can't think of anything
else that possibly needs to be planned
but I also am worried that there are
more things that need to be planned it's
a little overwhelming I was expecting
smaller desk I was hoping for like what
would look like an office this is a
conference room I guess I should have
known when they said it was a conference
room but this has like a long conference
room table machine that I had envisioned
was Jameson at his desk and Parker
sitting right in front of his desk it's
not gonna work here so just trying to
figure out how I want to block this now
Nico is gonna need to trust
Danny's writing
Danny's gonna have to trust Nico's
filmmaking experience if they can do
that it should work well it feels like
you just need the locations the actors
and then you're good but you really need
to iron out every single detail of how
the shoots gonna go that way it runs
smoothly and you don't show up on set
and have to just wing it
Studios have anyone need to be gracious
enough to use their main conference room
but they blocked that all the way out
from 8 a.m. to 2 p.m. so originally our
idea was to come a little later and
squeeze it out all the way to 2 p.m. but
we figured why not take advantage the
time slot they've given us as big here
as early as possible so it's 10:45 well
shoot as long as we need to no matter
what we have to be up by 2 but I'm not
worried about that we'll definitely be
done by then
moving back to downtown all right let's
do it
come on block this Peter we're gonna run
through blocking real good why are you
still here
so I'll cue the scream to happen and
just sort of like look around like you
hear something off in the distance and
you know you need to go help somebody
okay let's try to run through it one
time are you kidding me we've given a
more positive Meadows New York State
Jake may be saying did you just say
something why are you still here
and then he responds to that with yeah
okay I'm on it and so because he's
already saying Yale came on it and then
you say why do you why am I still here
it's like telling him to leave that very
artists that we make that yeah hopefully
they're going to do that after he's
after the woman screams yeah all right
so we're gonna grind these beans up very
fine into a fine powder because it's
gonna help the cacao to blend into the
water okay yeah dude I can feel it's so
strong what's so clear we're going to
boil some water I'm actually gonna add
in the cayenne pepper let it simmer for
a little bit and then I'll start adding
the actual cacao to the mixture stirring
it in bit by bit it's really up to the
cook how thick they want to make the
drink I've seen people at less water
which makes it more of a thick kind of
like smoothie like texture that's
actually smelling really nice so this is
tumeric and black pepper which I've seen
in a couple recipes
I don't know how historically accurate
these spices would have been but we're
gonna add them just
flavor and the healing properties as
well I'm actually gonna put in a little
bit of ginger next and then the cinnamon
so it's actually taking on this really
kind of thicker quality now that I've
been stirring it for a while like the
first time I ever came to the studio to
work on like snapper hero back in I
think 2014 you know I was kind of like
nervous because I hadn't been at this
studio before I hadn't worked the same
nikka for a while and went up here to
wash my hands and like I turned this on
there's like a spoon like perfectly
lined up with the water just like turn
it off goes everywhere it splashes me
such a dingus that's frigging splash boy
up here what's he doing oh the reason I
made this wasn't to like feel some crazy
effect it's just I think it's really
historically significant yeah I do think
it's cool so guys it's like something
else
it's a Mayan hot chocolate so we're bout
to go on a corridor digital spirit trip
in the ceremonies it is recommended that
you take every sip as a spiritual
endeavor and enjoy every sip what LSD
zip it you don't have to drink it all
right
wow that is heavy yeah
this is gross tastes about as good as it
looks feels like hot chocolate Maine
tastes like chocolate without the good
sweet part chocolate spicy no wonder
every sip is a spiritual journey eating
like the spiciness
it tasted like I took a shovel out to
like like a cemetery and just started
shoveling dirt into a cup and then very
spicy dirt have more I think you said it
tastes like dirt yeah oh you're so it's
good to know that I don't live in 1400
sent from Mexico and that's what I'm to
drink for spiritual journeys I think the
guy's foie gras Nick brings us dirt
beans I'd be down for some more really
good you're supposed to drink how many
asses to be under 100 on your full
journey I mean you guys all seemed
really stressed when I got back from
vacation okay you might not want to do
that why not hey what's that Carmichael
so you've been dealing with the
spider-man video yeah well it's a long
script also the end scene had Jane Mary
upside down the whole time we have a
scene in this in the video that requires
people to be hanging upside down while
eating dinner and quite frankly we just
don't really have the budget to pull it
off safely but came over the solution
and that is upstairs I have a pull-up
bar that I'll do inverted sit-ups on
Christina who's playing Jane Mary does
aerials and all kind of stuff so she has
no problem with just going inverted for
one shot which if we can write the
script for that one shot then we're good
did you do that Danny
we're good and there's this great scene
with a cop pulling over the spider-man
hurt it's not swinging fast enough but
we kind of realized that it's just kind
of an aside joke and it has a ton of the
effects work so we cut it or rather I
should say I cut it and hopefully
Danny's not mad at me
we'll see detect any wrinkles on that
forehead so we're good we brought it
down to a place where we can shoot it
with the resources that we have do you
know spider-man city's Sigma lenses the
art ones the best
hello it's going good
the first thing went really well we
knocked that out pretty quick and
efficiently now we're just waiting to
start this next scene this is the scene
where Parker is planning on proposing to
his girlfriend Jane Mary he also was
planning on telling her that he's not
spider-man it's a very pivotal scene in
any superhero movie when the love
interest finds out that the superhero is
the superhero or in this case he's not a
superhero for Danny and Nico do you know
Danny is great director I don't know how
much he's drunk in the past but he's
really shining crafting these
performances in a specific comedy style
that really you know translates from
vine to YouTube in a really nice way are
you legit feeling okay I'm great
don't play video games right now be
still good at dumb I'm pretty good I
feel like maybe a little lightheaded
I sort of think it might just be the
placebo effect it feels like a caffeine
shot almost you know it literally feels
like I just took an espresso shot yeah
do you think your arachnophobia is cured
do you feel more one with the spiders of
the world touching the spider
hello I give a slight lightheadedness
it's like drinking one beer nice right
how's it going dude yeah we just going
out to watch this is going out
tomorrow's I'm literally editing the
video that you're watching right now man
you guys never see like what happens the
day before release I stared at a light
and uh my eyes hurt so bright I'm just
gonna put it down low what do you got on
your plate today
a lot of renders I don't know I don't
know